[Music]
see i think there is a really
interesting relationship between
thinking about stoicism in modern times
and vulnerability and suffering because
i think they're related to each other i
don't think you deny your vulnerability
and your stoic will because you've
suppressed it i think you accept your
vulnerability
and that allows you to have it both in a
private but also an intimate sense if it
makes sense with with a friend or a
lover or a partner or whoever so i think
i don't think this should be posed as
one or the other i think they are very
very related now maybe this is because
i'm a therapist and can't contain their
feelings and they can't contain their
suffering whether it's rage or sorrow or
whatever it is
the the point of therapy is
in some sense for that feeling to be
transformed and live inside of them as
the hurt or whatever whatever the
fundamental feelings are and for them to
then contain it so i think they're two
sides of the same
coin really rather than
oppositional so so i mean i mean
happiness don't turn to you on this i
mean when you see it as being you know
unavoidable it's not something we choose
we can all agree with that
but is that something that
we kind of is is just unfortunate and we
have to deal with it always well do you
think it's it's kind of good that
there's some suffering in the world you
know
um and i suppose that's the thing i'm
not quite clear about when people talk
about suffering being beneficial whether
they think
uh we have to make them we have we did
we it's there we have to deal with it we
have to make the most of it we have to
sort of grow through it
but would it actually be better if we
just didn't have it at all i mean would
your life have been better if you didn't
have this real problem to overcome with
your own health for example
i think the question could be can we you
know if we were to um think of adversity
as a form of post-traumatic growth or
edification
one obvious question is well aren't
there easier ways to be edified
or to go to grow without having to have
the trauma first
it's an interesting
one and i think
i would say that
in terms of life as as we know it a life
without adversity would be so far
removed from anything recognizable to us
that it would it would just operate
under such radically different
conditions that's just quite hard to
imagine what it might be like to the
point where you might think
is it even useful beyond being a you
know
a sort of fantasy i suppose to think
about that
um and i think you know
i'll i'll call in freud if i may on two
points the first is
you know he famously said i'm not a
pessimist i'm i'm just a realistic
person i kind of
see what's
what reality is like what people are
doing to each other
you know writing back in the early 1930s
for example
um
and i i i can just offer this this this
idea that we we have to help each other
through these kinds of situations but we
mustn't delude
ourselves into thinking reality is any
prettier than than it is okay so that's
that's one thing the second thing which
i think
is profoundly important that he said he
said well
you can't get the good things if you're
not risking the bad things
so if you want to love someone that love
entails with it the possibility of loss
if you if you're invested in an ideal or
a goal
the risk of it not coming good or
falling apart or disappointing you is
always there
so
it's it's it's really just the kind of
the most fundamental emotional calculus
if you want to love if you want to get
attached if you want to gain
you have to make yourself vulnerable in
that way and you you're obviously making
yourself vulnerable to the possibility
of suffering and disappointment and pain
so in a way it's it's a it's a package
and i i don't think it's
really very um
i don't know how productive it is to ask
ourselves what would a human life look
like without
that whole that whole aspect because
it's not clear to me that it would
resemble in any way
how we live and who we are now well but
that's interesting i will turn to anders
in a minute because i think there are
kind of different kinds of suffering
right and now there are certain kinds i
think you alluded to
towards the second part of what you were
talking about like you know
relationships
projects things where the possibility of
failure is built in and if you don't
make yourself vulnerable to those
failures you also don't give yourself
the opportunity or the benefits and
that's true there are other things like
you know disease and illness well that's
not the case if we could snap up if i
could snap our fingers and and get rid
of um you know relationships and
projects because they had a risk of
suffering no one would do that we want
the rewards if i just snap my fingers
and there's no more cancer there's no
more of your lung disease there's no
most of us would say we would do that so
it seems like although some sufferings
are tied in um with with good things and
it is a package in other ways isn't and
i'm wondering whether in with that light
if we turn someone like anders as a
transhumanist
they're not perhaps quite the maybe not
quite the completely sunny uh utopians
that we might think that you want to get
rid of
some kinds of suffering right but you
even you think you can't get rid of all
suffering for the reasons that have
you've explained and you want to say a
little bit more about that yeah so my
friend david pierce
he wrote a big manifesto in the late 90s
the hedonistic imperative
where he laid out his project about
getting rid of suffering and only
maximizing pressure
and of course the obvious argument is
wait a minute how do you even function
in such a world
and he is arguing that there are great
information sensitive gradients of bliss
that would be directing the post-humans
in this world
now how that would actually work is an
interesting technical biological
philosophical problem which i don't
think anybody
but i think there is something
interesting but there are some forms
of suffering
that are instrumental
if i hurt myself pain signals and should
not just tell me that i need to be
careful about with the wounded part of
my body but also that i should
definitely stop doing whatever is
hurting it
and that links necessarily over to an
emotional system there is an emotional
component to pain which is where it ties
up with actual suffering rather than
just telling me that oh i stopped my
book
now we might want to modulate that
emotional part especially when it's not
relevant but there's other forms of
suffering like
social pain if i'm feeling a
lonely
so part of my brain get activated that
actually overlap with the
emotional part of the pain system even
though there is actually not at all any
physical component
now the really interesting thing is also
if i get disappointed
something was not as good as i had
expected it to be
then i also get this kind of activate
but that is a kind of common pathway now
we want to be information sensitive if
bad things happen i don't care
then i'm kind of failing at life i want
to fine tune this so i don't get that
unnecessary suffering and the really
tricky part of suffering is that it's
something that becomes part of us
i am suffering one of the best ways of
avoiding uh the pain and suffering is of
course to say there is suffering and say
that there is no self it's not tied to
me in particular that's a quite useful
trick you know sometimes when you're at
the dentist or something
but quite a lot of important things need
to be tied to our identity we try of
course argue that actually maybe having
that cohesive self
isn't that
haven't the buddhists been telling us
that we should give up on that maybe
there actually be other ways of
organizing how one functions that are
utterly different
and again
very interesting options here but i do
think that yeah i was suffering free
world would have to run on
in such a different way but we would say
those inhabitants are not not even not
quite human but actually quite different
and we on the other hand get a world
that has much less suffering and i think
yeah and we can still probably be
recognizably human because what i think
we want to do is deal with the
meaningful forms of adversity the stuff
that actually matters
quite a lot of the pains and aches we're
getting are just because of biology
telling us a signal over and over again
even when we already got the message and
we want to figure out ways to focus on
what matters for us to fix
i'm happy we want to come back to you on
that because i picked up on democracy
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai dot tv
for more debates and talks from the
world's leading thinkers on today's
biggest ideas
you